described the results as a mixed bag is
that a bit complacent
no i don't think it's complicated i
think it's a pretty accurate description
but it's a it's a pretty big
blow for 400
something of our our friends who have
stood as conservative councillors and i
tell you i was campaigning in places
like cumberland and wandsworth and
people like ravi govinda who have
devoted frankly a lifetime to serving
the people of wandsworth and people like
john malenson up in
in in carlisle have done similarly
for our community there is phenomenal
you know it's a real it's a real tragedy
i just want to talk specifically about
what's happening in the south and you
know you represent tornbridge and
malling you know in kent it's exactly
where the conservatives did badly uh
neighboring tumbridge worlds for example
losing control of that council election
just looking now at the conservatives
losing support in the south down 5.9
percent that average change in vote
share
in the south and mainly at the expense
of the liberal democrats why do you
think so many people in southern england
are turning against the conservatives
well you spoke to david simmons and that
came up a bit but i have to say one of
the things that came up even more for me
in the south of england was planning and
you know we need to address the fact
that the garden of england cannot become
the patio of england we need to make
sure that communities in across the
united kingdom have a say in what's
built near them by the way for many
people that means building more because
people want their friends and children
and family to come and live near them
but people do need to have control of
their lives and i think that's one of
the things that these elections have
really pushed hard as well because a lot
of the issues that have come forward
have not been the national issues that
you have been quite understandably
talking about a lot of them have been
down to local issues i mean i can
certainly tell you that in places like
tunbridge wells a lot of the issues have
been down to very local planning
decisions which people feel have gone
out of their control
at the same time though i just wonder
you know i spoke to david gork yesterday
as well and he was saying that he's got
concerned that by effectively leaning in
to some of the issues that he believes
are relevant in the red wall seats
brexit culture wars boris johnson has
been alienating some of the voters in
his more traditional blue shires if you
like do you think that that is true
well i mean you can
you you can talk about different
emphasis if you like i mean i think
british people across the entire uh
united kingdom want the same thing from
leadership they want integrity they want
clarity and honesty i mean i don't think
these are i don't think these are red
wall or or southeast or north east or
whatever issues these are national
issues
and i think people want the same but i
think
honesty just to come integrity and
honesty is partygate coming up quite a
lot then
well it's coming up a lot in parliament
look i mean there's some people who've
taken money off uh chinese uh people
have now been shown to be chinese agents
that's the lib dems there's some people
who are now being investigated for
various different things that's labor
that you know this is going across and
frankly a lot of us have had enough of
it you know it's not that hard
to remember that the people we all serve
the british people not ourselves and and
i do find it somewhat frustrating
sometimes to hear the cant from other
sides of the chamber and to watch what's
going on but it's also you know daisy
quite understandably said these boris's
rules on covert well she voted for them
i didn't hear her opposition during that
this was a pretty much the entire
parliament voted for it only a few of us
were built
i think daisy's point to be fair wasn't
about the covered rules themselves but
the fact that boris johnson
and then broke the coveted rules and
actually the question that i asked you
the question that i asked you was
whether or not that's coming up on the
doorstep so i'm not totally sure why
we're talking about chinese agents and
the lib dems but you know
because
an issue on the doorstep has
particularly been so if you ask me about
integrity and you're right to ask me
about integrity because it really
matters serving the british people
properly and remembering that this is a
duty and a service not you know some
sort of joyride is absolutely essential
but that applies across the entire house
and i'm afraid what has been so
frustrating in the last few years is how
many people across the whole house seem
to have forgotten that i'm not defending
anybody i'm not attacking anybody in
particular i'm just pointing out that
this is something that has become an
issue for the entire parliament and i
think we need to sort it out
is boris johnson still an electoral
asset to the conservative party
well it depends on the voter i mean
there are plenty of people who still
support him very closely and you know uh
in tunbridge and morning i can tell you
i get letters in support of him i get
that is against him and it's not
exactly surprising he's always been a
divisive character and he's always been
somebody who's communicated his message
extremely clearly and you can choose
which one of those uh skills or which
one of those aspects you you think is
most beneficial but you know we can
focus if you like on on the internal
politics but the most important thing
that happened on thursday wasn't boris
johnson the most important thing that
happened on thursday was the result in
northern ireland and the bank of
england's announcement that we may well
be going into recession and i have to
say those are the two things that are
going to be occupying my mind as we go
forward because holding the union
together and protecting our economy
therefore protecting the british people
in both senses i think is absolutely
fundamental so what do you want to see
from the government in relation to those
as you say extremely important issues uh
next week when the queen's speech
happens
well the first one on on northern
ireland i think it's listen to the
people of northern ireland you know we
have had a very very uh long-standing
principle embedded in various different
elements of the anglo-irish agreement
and the good friday agreement that the
consent of the people of northern
ireland is the paramount uh decision
you know decider of the outcome of
different
events there and so we do need to listen
and that means listening to people on
the east west trade and on the north
south trade i think we can resolve this
but it requires good will and
cooperation certainly uh uh across
across the island of ireland and across
the european union and across the united
kingdom and i think lowering the tension
is extremely important there the second
element on the economy i think there's
an awful lot that we can do i mean i
wasn't a supporter of the rise in
national insurance and i think there are
many other areas where we should be
looking at how we can ease the burden on
the british people because as we go into
a period where the bank of england is
telling us there's going to be slow
growth and the bank of england is going
to tell is telling us already that
inflation is running we're about to run
at somewhere near 10 percent and various
banks are telling us in private that the
for the lower down and for those poorer
in our community uh those who are
struggling more in our community it's
already running higher than that 10 15
you know we really do need to be looking
at this because this is about serving
the entire community and making sure
that people have what they need to
survive what's going to be likely to be
a very difficult time
you've previously said that you would
run for the leadership if boris johnson
was to go
is that still your position
well i've made it very clear um folks i
think i'm the only person who's made it
very clear that that i think serving our
country at every level is is an enormous
honor you know i've been lucky enough to
serve in uniform to serve as a diplomat
and now serving in parliament and i hope
you know i'll be able to serve in many
different ways and one of the ways of
course i'd like to serve uh our country
as uh you know
in a position that gives me influence
over the things that i think really
matter of course of course that's what i
want to do i i
came into parliament because i thought
that ideas matter that our country
matters in our communities matter and i
hope to serve a long time yet
and like you said in january as you were
mentioning there i think it's a position
of absolute integrity to say that of
course you should offer yourself to the
electorate if you think you can do it of
course you should talk to colleagues and
see if you can get a group together and
if you can get a group together you
should go for it have you been talking
to colleagues
not particularly no i mean the the the
real thing i've been doing at the moment
is dealing with the issues that you're
about to talk about when you speak to
the finnish ambassador i've spent an
awful lot of time speaking to people in
sweden and indeed finland and across uh
the the viking territories if you like
the northern uh the northern states uh
to
discuss both the nato element that i
hope you're going to be discussing with
the finnish ambassador which i must say
i'm very very pleased that the finns
have taken this decision or looked
likely to take this decision but i'm
also talking about different ways of
working with our european partners you
know for example you know youth mobility
schemes are not specifically covered by
the european union we can have them
separately the canadians have a separate
one with sweden why can't we you know
there's various elements that i'd like
to look at working with different
countries in different ways because i
think international outreach is
absolutely essential to our future and i
think britain is uniquely placed to be a
network power that brings people
together so i'm afraid that's where i've
been putting my focus